[Music]
what are you seeing as the state of
relationships
yeah they're a mess are
non-relational
patriarchal individualistic culture does
not teach men and women the skills we
need
to pull this off i love that you call
them skills
[Music]
yo yo yo what's up this is john with the
dr john delony show i hope you're doing
well hope your families are good
even your pet families
today only today only even your pet
families how about that um on the show
we talk about mental health
relationships we talk about everything
on the show you all know that um if you
want to be on this show go to
johndaloni.comask
a-s-k
and fill out the internet form and it
will shoot over to kelly and
sidekick jenna jenna's been helping a
lot jenna's crushing it back there jenna
sears um and um if you want to not go on
the internets because you were born in
the 14th century like me you can use the
telephone device
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 you can leave a message
so today is a special special show
this is a this is a
uh this is just awesome um and i'm kind
of even tongue-tied about it
right after i graduated um
with my counseling degree and i had
moved to nashville my life was in a mess
things were just sideways
um i had finished my research i was
trying to figure out how to be married
in this new town i was figuring out a
new job i was trying to figure out how
to be a dad everything was just a wreck
and i stumbled on a podcast says dr
peter tia and he was ranting and raving
about this book
by the one and only terence real terry
real and the book is called i don't want
to talk about it so i picked up the book
and i finished it in
a single
season single reading season and i
remember closing the book at my kitchen
table and i put my head down on the
table and wept in a way that i haven't
probably ever or maybe just a few times
and it was a before and after moment
things have to be different now and i've
given that book out good grief and y'all
heard me talk about this book i've told
people they need to go get that book and
read it wives read it husbands read it
everybody needs to read it
and i'm excited to say on today's show
we have the one only terry real as my
guest and as you listen to the show
you'll think
uh delaney says that a lot
a lot of it i got from him he's the guru
um you've heard me talk about esther
perel he is who she calls when she needs
some support he is who people call all
all over the world people reach out to
him for his expertise in relationships
um on the show we talk about
trauma a little bit
we talk about what's wrong with modern
therapy and some things that he is a
vocal proponent of changing when it
comes to therapy we talk about
loneliness we talk about relationships
marriage we talk about what what can
that husband do when his wife is
struggling with that wife can do my
husband's struggling talk about
everything talk about his new book
called us
everything in between as all interviews
with me go
there's gonna be some stuff you disagree
with great there's gonna be some stuff
that you're like whoa i never thought
about that anything deeper into that
fantastic some of it you're gonna think
all in all great
what i like to do is to bring people who
have moved me and motivated me and
challenged me and made me think deeply
people i vehemently disagree with and
people on who check all those boxes and
have a conversation with them and bring
that conversation to you so here's my
conversation with terry reel
all right so
terry reel
so
i was telling you off air how important
um
this opportunity to speak to you is and
when when we first sat down and started
the podcast a couple years ago and it's
taken off when we started discussing
interviews there was always hey give us
a list to learn to give us a list
all of those lists you are number one
and
for
for a number of reasons here's the main
reason
i graduated um with my fancy pants
counseling phd i thought i was the
smartest idiot in the room
and then i stumble across
um
i was really interested in how nutrition
interacted with mental health and so i
was
an early
student if you will from via the
internet of dr tia
who then said hey there's this one book
and so here i am this fancy graduate and
i go pick up i don't want to talk about
it
and i bet i've given that book out 200
times in the past few years
it is
easily the number one most important
non-fiction book i've ever read
and it i remember being so deflated
thinking how did i get through an entire
program and nobody told me this
and it was a paradigm shape-shifter um
especially
my focus is my research was on working
with people who had quote unquote made
it
and then found themselves isolated alone
and they melt everybody around them and
then here was this masterpiece that you
wrote so
on behalf of all especially of us men
but of the of the spouses and everybody
thank you for putting that into the
world all right so here's question
number one
uh this is a conversation about the
current state of relationships and
coming out of covid relationships in
general whether they're work
relationships dating relationships
marriage relationships parenting
everything feels like a mess
where are you seeing
the state of relationships i know that's
a broad question answer it as you will
what are you seeing as the state of
relationships
yeah they're a mess yeah uh they're
they're a mess for a couple of reasons
um
one is uh
i've written about this pretty
extensively
um
things are changing
and we're not completely caught up with
ourselves
in heterosexual relationships
i believe
that women across the board
north south east west whatever
are asking for
new levels of emotional connection and
intimacy from us men
then we raise boys and men to deliver
um
what it means to be a man traditionally
is to be invulnerable the more
invulnerable you are the more manly you
are the more vulnerable you are the more
girly you are
and that is true to this day
uh you may
raise your son differently in your
little hot house nuclear family but
trust me
that kid knows the score once he hits
the playground that's right
women girls and women have changed
dramatically over the last 50 years and
us guys have not
and
there's a raw disjuncture
women want men to be vulnerable they
want men to share their feelings
to
be compassionate to the woman's feelings
to be you know we've never wanted more
from our relationships than we want
right now
in our grandparents generation
you know if
you got along nobody beat anybody nobody
cheated or drank too much you were okay
nowadays
uh we want long walks on the beach
holding hands and heart-to-heart talks
and great sex and there are six we
really want to be lifelong lovers
but our
non-relational
patriarchal individualistic culture
does not teach men and women the skills
we need to pull this off
and people have outsized ambition
about wanting to be close for life but
we just don't know how to do it we don't
know how
to stand up for ourselves and be loving
at the same time we don't know how to
listen to our partners and not get
defensive we don't know how to repair
when the wheels come off we don't know
how to negotiate
we don't know how to cherish a lot of us
guys
and uh you know i would like basic
relationship skills taught
in uh elementary school and junior high
and high but we don't do that i love
that you call them skills uh when when i
encourage couples to practice things
they look at me like i'm nuts
and if we can distill these things down
into series of
skills that we just don't have
okay so
um help me with this
i'm a lifelong texan i was born and
raised in texas before i came here and
99
of the stereotypes are accurate right so
what do i do
to with with i'm sitting by the man who
says all right i sat down and told my
wife how i felt and she has bought into
the i don't want some vulnerable man
either
um like she's playing she's contributing
too right oh so funny john that is the
first thing i hear from guys every time
i talk about you
well i want to but my chick doesn't
really want me to
you know so is that nonsense is it just
nonsense
well if it's a mixed bag
look
when i talk about the culture of
patriarchy
uh women participate in that culture
just like men do
but women are giving us guys mixed
messages on the one hand i want you to
be strong i don't want you to be you
know a wimp on the other hand
uh i want you to be able to share your
your feelings and then when you do i
might get uncomfortable when you do so
okay
like be a man like say to your gal
excuse me
it wasn't that you just telling me
[Laughter]
now that i do like you're really putting
an apron on me you know give me a break
like you got me coming and going
confront the issue of the mixed message
because that is true but don't take that
as an excuse to lay down and not listen
to the other half of the message look
what we know from research
is that we human beings connect
to vulnerability
that's how we that's how we share
uh emotionally
and uh
being vulnerable is news to a lot of men
certainly texas guys
hey boston guys too boston guys too
oh it's true it's just a
different way of doing it that's right
and
uh and um gals too i had about speaking
about boston i had a gal uh blue collar
boston irish you know boston southie
kind of matt damon plays in in the
movies and uh i said how how how are you
doing and she said good
and i said can you give me two syllables
she said
good
exactly exactly all right hey let's talk
about
um
something has become an obsession of
mine over the last decade if you were to
ask me what are if i was to distill down
the a cornerstone issue
the word i would give you is
pathological loneliness i think we have
a the like an incredibly lonely culture
and i was so
grateful that you you touched on that i
mean that's kind of the theme of this
book when when i read through it is this
idea of loneliness
talk to me about that am i crazy um or
is are we just cross this threshold of
loneliness i feel like we're asking our
bodies to do things that no bodies have
been asked to do in human history which
is do everything alone
you know uh we we do have an episode of
loneliness and we're lonely even when
we're with each other right
you know
if somebody asked me in an interview why
do i think they call american college
kids anyway
get drunk all the time every time they
go out with each other i mean [ __ ]
shit-faced drunk
and
and i say well because they don't know
how to be with each other there you go
yeah they don't want to have a simple
they don't have to have a conversation
with each other so now we're lonely by
ourselves and we're lonely with other
people too and the book us
is a critique of what i call the toxic
culture of individualism
mine
and we have to wake up
to understand
that we humans are not built to be alone
i start with our brains our neural we we
neurobiologically
do not
self-regulate our brains interact with
other brains all day long and we need to
or we go nuts if you want to look at
a so-called free
rugged freestanding individual look at
somebody in solitary confinement they go
crazy yes
our brains need other brains to
communicate or we go
haywire so we need each other
what i say john is
our relationships are our biosphere
we are in it we are we breathe
uh those
so you can choose in your marriage for
example
to pollute your biosphere by having a
temper tantrum over here
but you're going to breathe in that
pollution in your partner's withdrawal
or lack of sexuality you're connected
the culture of individualism teaches us
we're not in it we're apart from it
we're individuals and that
goes along with patriarchy which you
know i've been writing about for 30
years it says we're not only apart from
nature we dominate it we're above it and
we control it whether we control our
wives or our kids or our bodies they're
going to lose 10 pounds or our heads
i've got to be less negative is control
control control and what i say in the
book
is that the model of dominance and
control
is lethal it will make a mess of our
relationships it screws up our
self-esteem our relationship with
ourselves it will screw up our planet if
we're not careful we must trade in this
delusion
of being above
our
our relationships and lording it over
them for what i call ecological humility
we're in the damn thing we breathe you
know i got these big burly guys
and they say to me hey why should i have
to work so hard to make my wife happy
and i go
knock knock
[Music]
you live with them okay
oh my god so talk to me about friendship
then um
going back to skill set one of the most
probably the number one common question
i get is
i'm 41 and i don't have any friends or
i'm 37 and i don't know how to make
friends and we we you know we grow up in
elementary school middle school high
school college it's all everything's
communally oriented right and then they
dump you out into the real world and say
kill or be killed
important is having friends outside of a
romantic relationship
oh my god it's critical
and it takes a lot of the burden off of
the romantic relationship oh it's so
good to hear you say that okay tell me
more about that
for guys so many guys put all their eggs
in one basket you know the only one who
sues them the only one who listens to
them the only one who cheers them is
their uh is their romantic partner go
get some friends for chrysler
yes dude it makes my heart feel good
but you have to
you have to break that membrane and i
and i and i teach guys this you have to
you know yeah okay sports and politics
that's good talking about your kids is a
little better
but
you know what actually
you know uh my wife and i had a fight
the other week
and uh uh it really rattled me
or i i
i'm having a health scare and
i'm a little scared or i just look in
the mirror damn i'm old
[Laughter]
take the thing a little deeper dare to
be a little more personal yeah and this
is what i say do that you know look you
may not have friends but you damn well
have acquaintances
so drive those acquaintance
relationships a little deeper
and if you do that with four people
two of them will let you know that
they're not interested at all
one of them will change the subject and
one of them will go
oh man that's terrible tell me more
about it or oh yes i've been looking
kind of old myself and that is your new
friend right do want and and dare to
drive things a little deeper but it's
that same thing
you have to risk vulnerability whether
it's with your romantic partner or with
a pal
it has to go a little deeper than you
know what iron are you going to use
oh man oh it makes me feel so good it
makes me feel like i'm not crazy thank
you so so much
hey good people dr john deloney here and
i know we all want to feel better
mentally physically emotionally and i
mean think about the goals you've set
the diets you've started the workouts
you've tried the routines you've
adjusted to change for the better but
despite all that effort you're probably
overlooking one of the easiest changes
you can make that's guaranteed to help
you out
getting good sleep trust me seven to
nine hours of quality sleep every night
will change your life for the better and
quality sleep starts with a quality
mattress and that's why i love
dreamcloud dreamcloud mattresses are
made with advanced technologies that
keep you comfortable all night long and
right now dreamcloud is running their
biggest offer ever exclusively for our
listeners when you order a mattress you
now get 499 dollars in sleep accessories
like pillows a mattress protector and
luxury sheets plus an additional 250
cash discount for john de loni show
listeners that's a total of 749 dollars
in accessories and savings if it's time
to change your sleep for the better
visit dreamcloudsleep.com
and enter promo code deloney to get your
new mattress today
so let's talk trauma for just a second
before we get into
something i've been wanting to talk to
you about since i read this first book
um how would you define trauma
injury hurt
and um but is hurt
that lands on you in a way that freezes
you ah
well you don't get over it you you uh
you you cauterize it you corral it
and
and it stays there
and
and then you adapt to it
we're very resilient
creatures
so um
[Music]
uh maybe i talk about fight
flight
freeze or fix
uh and uh
maybe when you were hurt maybe my dad
was as you know from the first book was
a depressed angry violent guy
and uh and i'm a fighter
and so uh belinda criticized my wife
criticizes me
the immediate thing that happens is that
little three four-year-old in me
gets activated and i'm that little boy
and she's my screaming critical father
i'm right back there the thing to know
about trauma is you don't remember it
you relive it yeah
back there it's in your body right
body right so i'm in i'm back being that
three-year-old i have like a lot of
people about two seconds worth of
tolerance
for that young wounded place and i click
right into action and i go into the
adaption
that i uh created
at that early age i fight
so is
um
has some good disagreements um recently
on this topic
how would you classify yelling is
yelling i i'll just just feel the beans
i think yelling is
abuse i think yelling can be traumatic
um particularly when it's when
there's
there's power differential there um i'm
but i'm i'm i'm willing to be corrected
here am i am i overselling yelling um it
seems to be one of those things that
goes unnoticed in homes that just has
ripple effects through family
generations there
you know um it depends on the energy of
it okay
yeah you could be a big italian family
hey come on get get your ass down here
come on
uh and uh
and then everybody's laughing five
minutes later and the volume isn't
what's so important
if if yelling is uh connected to a
personal attack
you're an [ __ ] you've always been an
[ __ ] that's a whole different story
there we go okay so it's not necessarily
the volume itself it's what's it about
what what's going on in the interaction
excellent okay
so i want to turn right here for a
minute and talk about
the state of
therapists today
um one of my f as a
as a somebody who's trained to train
counselors i love you you don't mind
shaking up the snow globe on traditional
psychotherapy and in fact almost demand
that it be done differently if we want
to continue to help people yeah
so when i look at
modern therapy in some ways that it's
been really helpful in some ways it's
failed us um here's a couple of things
i've noticed over your work that i'd
love to talk through one is this idea of
talk versus action
we come from this world that we can just
talk about it and talk about it and talk
about it and if you just have this the
right thoughts about something that
magically is different
you take a different approach you give
people
you have to do this stuff differently
talk to me about that
well it's in the doing
uh
you know
my dad uh weighed about 250 pounds he
had a giant potbelly uh but he was an
expert on exercise he'd read every
exercise book in the world
[Laughter]
we used to say in the family we had the
best exercise eyeballs in town
you got to do this stuff you can't just
sit around and think about it where did
we get sideways there where where do we
get
uh where did where did the field jump
the tracks there
i don't know and i don't care this is my
message to you oh i love that good for
you that's awesome i don't care uh
people always tell you that
relationships take work but nobody tells
you what it is yeah
and here's what i want to tell you and
your listener
the work of relationships
is not even day to day it's minute to
minute
this minute right now when i'm triggered
and i want to talk about that in a
minute when i'm triggered when the
automatic response that adaptation
comes over me fight flight freeze or fix
what am i going to do am i just going to
roll with it and start screaming at my
wife or am i going to you know
stonewall and shut the conversation down
the way i always do am i going to do the
same damn thing i always do
and by the way get the same result i
always get
well in this moment
right now
am i going to take a breath
reach for a different part of me
it's literally a different part of your
brain
do some breathing we do a lot of
breathing and relational work people
walk around the block take a take a
break we talk a lot about taking breaks
get re-centered
in the part of me that has my head on
straight
and then come back into
the phrase i talk john about what i call
remembering love
remembering that the person you're
speaking to is someone you love and the
reason why you're speaking is to make
things better
somebody said wait why am i talking if
that's why you're talking you're good if
that's not why you're talking
i have great advice for you you ready
[Laughter]
go for it no no
oh
man so
walk around the block and get yourself
re-centered until you do remember
what this is about it's literally a
different part of your brain that you
have to get into
but
i feel like our culture has told a
generation or two or three of people
that
you can't con
you can't control that
yeah right that's the news in my book
like you can't you can't con like sorry
man that's just how i am i'm just being
me my feelings are valid so i'm just i'm
deciding i'm gonna vomit them all over
you
i i'm just calling bullcrap on the whole
thing
we have to look at people and say right
and say no no i'm you have to
somebody called recently and said how do
i stop yelling i said stop yelling right
i don't want to over complicate this
stop yelling decide i'm a person who
never yells right terry how do we fix
the it's a cultural disempowerment that
you have no control over you
and um i don't know i don't know i don't
even know where to start other than just
to launch in and say no you can you can
you can do something when it comes to
these hot moments
you may need to take a break right
you should go to my website if i can of
course
my name terryreel.com
t-r-y-r-e-a-l i have a one-pager on the
ten commandments on how to take a
timeout
take a timeout if you need to a formal
timeout you can stay out all day long if
you need i'll tell you a story i was
working with a gal a little little flip
of a thing very very but she was a rager
man yelling screaming throwing places i
mean the whole thing
and she'd been raised by a rager
and we talked about ending the legacy of
violence for her her husband and her
kids
and i taught her how to take a timeout
you have to check it it's all written
down you have to check in at 15 minutes
an hour three hours a half a day a whole
day and overnight all right
she started the rage
she locked herself in her bedroom it's
absolutely true story
she said i'm not getting out and
inflicting this on my family i'm done
with this rage
she gave herself a timeout
she did breathing she had a little
chance with her little girl who was so
angry she did all the stuff
but she'd feel great
walk over to the bedroom door grab the
handle the door to open the door and
woof the rage would come back
she was in that bedroom for a day and a
half
[Music]
every 15 20 minutes she'd walk to the
door think she had a knock and that rage
would come back her husband bless his
heart
uh gave her a little plate
you know with a sandwich and potato
chips
slid it under the door like hannibal
lecter
shut the door
anyway she came out the next morning
and it was over
all control and she never raged again
and so what i tell people is if you
stand there you may not be able to
control what comes out of your mouth but
you do have control you can turn around
if you agree to it in advance your
partner knows what's going on now you go
you turn heel and you get the hell out
that's called a timeout and what you
have to understand
if you're one of these people who spills
all this crap out
your children are watching
uh this is probably how you grow up
you don't want to hand this down there's
an old saying pass this back or pass it
on there's nothing this is what i tell
my clients
and i'm a razor i'm a razor in recovery
in that moment i don't care what the
damn point is
there is nothing more important than
breaking the chain of this legacy of
violence
stop the violence the emotional violence
and everything else is everything else
concentrate on that keep your mouth shut
and get the hell out until you can
control yourself i love that there's
something so profound about a never
again moment even if it takes a day and
a half or two days or what that's that's
incredible
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy we don't do
it and we don't even realize they won't
even think about it
you are worth it
this month betterhelp online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john deloney show
listeners get 10 off their first month
so decide to invest in yourself you are
worth it and go to
betterhelp.com delony to get 10 off
that's betterhelp.com
uh one more thing that sets you apart
from other therapists there's many many
things one of them is
and this is this made me smile the first
time i read it and i just have come to
love it you take sides let's talk about
that in a therapy session so for those
for the listener
therapists are trained and not not
trained it is it is this is cast in
stone and etched on your soul
you are simply a neutral third party and
you let people have their interactions
um you let people bring in in a singular
session they bring their own level of
xyz to you and if you take sides it's
can be considered unethical and what i
have found is it's unethical to let
somebody sit there and drown
in a session
um with this hope that that that truth
somehow materializes in the room and you
have said no more right talk to me about
that
no more listen you can have a uh
alcoholic
rager
bipolar untreated person
with no medication no treatment for
their alcoholism no treatment for their
rage and the other person's
quote-unquote contribution is guess what
they're there i mean this is [ __ ]
not all problems are 50 50. and in the
work i do and i train therapists all
over the country if you're a therapist
listening come to my website and train
with us we have a two-year training
program it's great
and not only me but at all relational
life therapists the method i've created
take sides not we're we're perfectly
happy to say
uh uh
bill
uh you're a nut
[Laughter]
sylvia you're an even bigger nut and
here's why
uh bill uh
when your wife confronts you
you pull down the shade uh you stop uh
you break connection you take no
responsibility for anything of course
she goes out of her mind oh and by the
way jill you go out of your mind
you go and scream withdrawing now look
i'll help you with with bill's distance
but anybody's going to be distant if
you're standing there screaming at them
so you go first
let's calm you down and uh stop your
verbal abuse and then i'll work with
your husband and yes we take turns we
call it like we see it
and
this nonsense of well what do you think
well what do you think
well this is a revolutionary way of of
working and i go around the country
telling a therapist that it's a huge
design flaw in therapy and you know
partner a brings partner b in to see me
to render them more livable more
relational
and uh
most couples there say oh we don't take
that on that's for individuals no
we're in the personality transplant
business oh i like that
i want to turn your partner into a
connected
sensitive responsive relational human
being you bring them to me and i'll take
care of it and it's often a woman
bringing in a man but not always
but when they do
you know
you know this john i specialize in
couples on the brink of divorce that no
one else has been able to help and when
i take on
the difficult partner
and i say here's what i say
listen
if i'm dealing let's do it straight up
it's not always this way but let's do a
heterosexual couple where the woman is
the unhappy one and the guy is
taking liberties a womanizer a drinker
uh
irresponsible a rager or whatever
and i say to the woman
you've been heard today
and the woman is often angry i'll say to
the guy an angry woman is a woman who
hasn't been hurt then i'll turn to the
woman you've been hurt today i got him
everything you're saying about him is
true i get it
now but you are not going to get through
to him i will
you give it to me
your job is to relax
breathe and see if you can enjoy the son
of a gun a little bit because
but i will take him on and i'll teach
him how to do this and when i do
i got to tell you it's not like whatever
but
99 out of 100 times the other partner
man or woman who's brought the person in
it cries yeah
from relief and they say we brought this
person to
six other therapists and not one of them
have taken them on
it's almost like you're you're restoring
the parental role that should have been
there
25 or 35 years ago that looked at that
little kid and said hey i'm i got this
you're okay
yeah that's right and also the parental
that says to the uh
the
the jerk don't do that yeah
yeah it's both oh man i love it
all right let's spend the last few
minutes we got tell me about this new
book obviously it was written during
a time of chaos can i can i make one
observation about this
and i can edit it out if you don't want
me to put in here one
phenomenal work here
this has a
[Music]
there was a sense of optimism in your
first couple of books
this one felt more like a sense of
realism
like some of these things like
i had i as i was going through it i
thought
i wonder if terry looks is looking
saying okay this thing is just
in the 90s we thought we could stop the
thing from running it's running now so
here's how to live with it running the
way it is am i am i out to lunch there
is that there's an underlying sentiment
there that just felt this book was
different than your other ones
i don't think it's pessimistic john
here's what i say
to be perfectly honest
i think that um
i think that we're in the middle of uh
a society at war with itself yeah
i think that the dominance
individualistic power over model that we
all grew up with part of masculinity
that's right and it's regional
but i think that that dominance uh model
uh
it plays havoc
it with our relationship with ourselves
you know i gotta lose ten pounds i gotta
stop thinking like this
uh in our relationship to our uh uh
those who love us
we try and control our kids or our
partners our planet
um
and we're either going to trade in
uh that model for a
a model of interdependence
we live with each other
we live that we live with nature not
above it and in control of it
and i think that
there are the two factions
uh one heading uh toward a different
view of our relationship to nature and
one very much reasserting a very old
traditional view
are
are fighting with each other right now
i love it
uh i think that
uh
which side wins
a collaborative model versus a dominus
model
uh will have a lot to do with the kind
of society we're all living in uh a
hundred years from now
and the planet we're on a hundred years
from now because we know nothing
of uh uh how we feel between our ears
and how we feel with others you know i'm
proud to say
that none other than bruce springsteen
wrote the following i know man i saw
that it's incredible congratulations man
you first go forward with a quote
uh from from the book which i think in
some ways summarizes the book
the quote he picked was this
uh
this world does not belong to us
we belong to one another
and we're gonna figure that out or the
consequences are gonna be dire yeah
and and
to the listener there
that sounds um in some ways like uh okay
or subtle
it is a 180 degree transformative way of
experiencing everything right and living
into everything it's a it's such a
radical shift i think it's so radical
it's hard to even see it sometimes
i'm proud about
is that
i give you the map how to live as if
you're inside the relationship not
outside of it but i also give you tools
very concrete tools that's the beauty
yes
you give them you give us a
play-by-play right this is
the
um
it's as though you and i are sitting
down together like we can't all we can't
all have you as our personal
relationship therapist but it's this is
pretty dang close right it's it's just
right there together man um
what do you tell the
woman who's husband is busy and he's
kind and she quote unquote i love him
but he's just separate give her a word
of encouragement and then we'll flip the
script here
stand up because instead of a gun
[Music]
assert yourself
i want for women more uh i want women to
be more proactive on the front end and
less resentful on the back end
but you have to know how to do it with
love
in our patriarchal individualistic
culture you either stand up for yourself
or you love the guy and the relationship
but you don't do both at the same time
oh brand new territory i said i give you
tools here's a tool it's called standing
up for yourself with love
i love you honey i'm beginning to build
up a bunch of resentment i'm feeling
turned off sexually i'm not feeling
close to you i want to be close to you i
want to be your lover i need more from
you so that the juices can continue to
flow between us don't you want that too
what can i do to help you come true for
me try that one
this is the brave new world what can i
do
to help you
come through for me who sounds like that
unless they've broken they've learned
how to ah it's incredible so let's flip
it um
to the husband whose
um
wife has gotten really busy and she's um
running around from thing to thing thing
and he can feel her losing confidence in
herself give that guy a piece of
encouragement
um
[Music]
listen to her
let her be the lead
don't be her professor don't be your
daddy uh
and
you know if the issue really is that you
think she's losing confidence in herself
tell her that that's what you're saying
and that's what you're that's the story
you're telling yourself but with
humility not like the expert you know
god's gift on the other hand
i hate to tell you but what you might be
really saying underneath that is honey i
miss you there you go oh yes there it is
we're so busy with this and the other
thing he's so buried in the kids
uh how about a little lost sign
and i do believe that american culture
is way too child-centric
take some time off get a babysitter go
to a hotel
you know you want to improve your sex
life take her someplace sexy for a
weekend and treat her like a queen uh
this business
we give too much away to everybody else
and
our romantic relationship is last in the
time creditor line give us some air to
breathe and give us some cherishing oh
my gosh
well this is a
um
i was gonna say career this is a
personal highlight um it's you're you're
an absolute treasure and a gift and i'm
grateful for your time
and for um everybody listening to this
um you will
think to yourself
i thought dallona you've been saying
that i know i got it from from terry
that's where it came from
so
uh man what a gift so where can people
pick up this book it's it's in pre-sale
now right
yeah you can order you can go to amazon
and pre-order it okay it's coming out
when is this going to be uh air can i
say
um they're
the producers looking at me
may 27th
okay it's coming out the following week
june 7th very good but um
pre-order it now and um
uh this is a good time to order it yes
well hey i am
super grateful for you um thank you for
your time and i wish you all the best
and uh i hope you sell
several million copies of this book man
fantastic
i think it deserves it and uh thank you
for your work i really appreciate it oh
hey real quick before before we wrap up
every show always end with the song of
the day
what is your favorite song ever
do you have a favorite song ever
uh my favorite song ever has gotta be
bruce springsteen's the rising oh gosh
what an incr that whole record is
incredible
man you just became i didn't think you
could get cooler man
you roll in here with a really cool
necklace and then you drop springsteen
good grief all right that's how we'll
wrap up today's show man hey thank you
my brother i'm grateful for you and take
care and um
good health and lots of laughter and joy
thank you it goes both ways you keep
doing well take care
hi dad
hey deloney here one of the things i
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show
your stories are incredible and each
person's situation is unique and for
years people from all over the world
have been asking if i do private
counseling or private coaching sessions
for them or for their spouse and as much
as i'd love to i can't realistically do
one-on-one coaching sessions with every
single person it's just not possible but
that's exactly why i wrote my new book
own your past change your future within
the pages of this book is exactly what i
would say if you and i were sitting down
together at a table looking for the next
right move for you to make in your
relationships or to help you live a more
whole and peaceful life
as you read through each section of this
book i will show you how to look and own
the roads from your past and head to the
new roads of a well life moving forward
go to johndaloni.com to get your copy
today that's own your past change your
future at johndaloni.com
all right we are back and as we wrap up
the show with the one and only terry
reel
man he picked a doozy what an
extraordinary song this one's
um by the boss bruce springsteen and the
song is called the rising and it goes
like this
can't see nothing in front of me can't
see nothing coming up behind make my way
through this darkness i can't feel
nothing but this chain that binds me
lost track of how far i've gone how far
i've gone how high i've climbed on my
backs a 60 pound stone on my shoulder a
half mile line come on up for the rising
come on up lay your hands in mind come
on up for the rising tonight
their spirits above and behind me faces
gone black eyes burning bright may their
precious blood bind me lord as i stand
before your fiery light
come on up for the rising lay your hands
in mind we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode so topic
of my question is on gun ownership and
oh cool we're just gonna come out uh
we're gonna come out uh we're gonna slow
roll this one out of the gate way to go
all right let's talk guys this is the
point i didn't tell anyone for
about a year and after it happened
and when i did tell my mom
um she didn't believe me you know she
asked me the typical questions like what
were you wearing so you have the initial
trauma which is
wrong it's evil
and then you turn to the one remaining
adult in your life and say help
and she says what were you wearing